[Music]
Barbara Walters built a career of Firsts
she was the first female co-host of
NBC's Today Show the first female to
co-anchor a network nightly newscast
Barbara Walters and she hosted what is
still one of the most watched television
news programs ever her sit-down
interview with former White House intern
Monica Lewinsky about her affair with
former President Bill Clinton why did
you tell Linda Tripp about this dress
because it was funny
it was funny throughout her career
Walters proved she had the grit to ask
the tough questions and ever winced when
she got back uncomfortable answers it
wasn't an affair it wasn't love
sex Walters never shied away from
grilling disgraced politicians world
leaders and beloved celebrities
including Princess Grace Johannes I must
ask you the question that most Americans
want to know about you are you happy
tributes to Walters have flooded social
media Oprah Winfrey writing without
Barbara Walters there wouldn't have been
me basketball great Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
tweeting Barbara Walters never flinched
when questioning the world's most
powerful people she held them
accountable Katie Couric writing her
body of work is unparalleled and Tennis
Superstar Billie Jean King calling
Walters a true Trailblazer
launched the talk show The View in 1997
which is still on the air on the day she
signed off fellow journalists honored
her for Paving the way for their own
careers in an industry once dominated by
men this is my legacy these are my
legacy her Legacy also included a slew
of Emmy nominations and wins two
lifetime achievement awards and her own
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame I'm
Barbara Walters and this is my show the
10 Most Fascinating People Walters was
the woman who got to ask the famous
questions we all wanted to ask and
brought those conversations into our
homes
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington